I want to steal your wardrobe you are
the most fun person I'm a meme ever met
I love you okay they don't like this
please in here yeah this is actually an
intervention
no but Chauvin josie that's not your
real name right no no what's your real
name Maya Maya swear you the name Maya
well I'm from South Africa but when I
was born my parents were reading dr.
Maya Angelou mm-hmm and I think they
wanted a daughter who was literate so
[Laughter]
someone who writes beautifully and yeah
my gosh it's amazing you are like a look
at them I'm not it's aim higher I swear
I have gone to South Africa many times
that is a long flight thank you for
finding clear across the world to be
here yeah very very excited but tell me
about your John Cena song a what
inspired I love the video I'm Bay how
loved the song thank you so much I love
John Cena
[Applause]
oh yeah okay I'm growing up I was
already I grew up in a very rural area
Limpopo in South Africa and there was
one television in my village while we
were growing up and we got to watch two
TV shows one was local drama called
generations and Allah knows wrestling so
if I didn't go by show my jersey I would
have gone by John Cena probably
someone's name so I made this song cause
it's really like about you know cuz John
Cena always used to say you can't see me
so when we used to play wrestling with
my cousin's I used to pretend to be John
Cena I love you I just pictured you like
eight years old just like giving it to
like you can't see me you know and so
yeah so then recently I had this boy
that I really like and then he just
didn't notice me ever so I was like this
guy can't see me maybe like him already
thank you he can't see me maybe I'm John
Cena did you ever actually get to meet
him after you did this who John Cena oh
no of course not it's a whole yeah well
that's a bummer I mean I think he posted
did he post about it as well and when he
found out I don't know if he posts for
himself but his page he put he put the
picture of me on there he doesn't say
anything he doesn't caption he doesn't
tag me and nothing he's because you
can't see you
[Applause]
I'm gonna you got a guy on it I love him
a lot
all right well it's a first season he's
not here bring it over my budget
but I'm just thinking watching but wait
see he's watching and he's gonna love
this moment and I want you to perform
this song will you Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so what do you want to say to show she
loves you first of all thank you for the
kind words while I was hiding back there
I was hiding the whole time I do post
myself and I don't caption anything
because I kind of don't want the viewer
of the account to I want them to take
away what they can't and people are
finding inspiration in your song and
here's what you don't know and she
explained it very candidly but her song
is about essentially about heartbreak
right but it's really cool because it's
a high energy song and you could take
something negative in your life and
express it creatively and you've
literally reached an audience around the
world she's from South Africa
geographically around the world you
managed to create a dance challenge in
my name we saw that I can't dance around
don't you ever do a song I just I still
got some bars the real it's not a fake
so that's I can't imagine being it I
can't imagine actually you're a child
and he grew up loving these people and
that you idolized them and they they
change you you know they've made such an
impact on you and it's awesome to get to
meet them like in real life where live
it's the coolest thing
that's the spewing that song
so so I've been in WWE a long time
almost 20 years and you forget the
impact that you have on people and
hearing that song I'm like you're cool
I'm not makes me half cool again really
I'm so very excited in to know that you
know essentially what I did had an
impact on people around the world that's
also really cool it's just us nobody's
watching I think you're the coolest ever
Wow that's it I think you've accrued
over like I would have gone by John Cena
fatwas if you weren't already not really
my name my dad's name is John Cena so if
if you want to borrow it it's got legs
it's not your real name oh it is my real
name was not my name my dad's name is
also John Cena so maybe you were saying
at family functions we have to fight to
the death the name for the evening
you stick with showing everyone around
the world knows show me just subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going